be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos rice plane things outside of
comic books
so what I want to do here is be a little
bit dangerous
and dip my toe in the waters of Marvel's
what-if stories now for those of you
guys who don't know
Marvel's what-if line of comics
basically deal with alternate realities
it could be that things are very similar
to our own or it could be that things
are radically different for example my
video on Wolverine kills the Marvel
Universe
that's a what-if story what if Hydra and
the hand had not been stopped and
Wolverine had stayed under their control
well then he basically just killed all
the superheroes on earth that was
effectively the story but these what-if
issues when we're going to be talking
about today actually of the Punisher
becoming Captain America actually comes
out of the age of Ultron event now for
those of you guys who never saw my
videos on that series it was written by
Brian Michael Bendis and it basically
centered on the idea of Ultron taking
over the future and then using the
vision in the present as a way to take
over the present to effectively kill off
superheroes of course it dealt a lot
with the timestream and different things
like that and Mendes made it very very
complicated but the long and short of
the story was that when it came to its
end
Wolverine had rationalized that Hank Pym
would always create Ultron it was just
in his genes as a scientist he just had
to know whether or not he could create
artificial intelligence and so even if
Wolverine had traveled into the past and
talked him out of creating Ultron at
some point in the future Hank Pym would
have made him anyway just out of sheer
curiosity then as a result wolverine
said that the only way to stop Ultron
from coming into existence was to kill
Hank Pym and so while wolverine was
successful in killing him the result was
that because tom was basically a living
constructs and because people had
travelled into the past throughout the
history of Marvel Comics and meddled
with time so much Wolverines actions
were the straw that broke the camel's
back and quite literally time broke and
it sent a whole bunch of ripples into
the multiverse changing things in their
entirety now while this was used by
Marvel as a way to basically tie into
Hickman's Avengers and do Avengers in
order to start Secret Wars with regards
to this particular comic this just shows
us one of the multiverses I
it's one of the universes in the
multiverse that was impacted by
Wolverines actions and in this story
what model does is they basically open
up by giving us the regular gamete of
Captain America stuff that is to say
when he was first discovered by the
Avengers and Avengers issue number four
they give us a little bit of his a
history with regards to him and Bucky
Barnes fighting together in World War
two
but what Marvel also does is they tell
us that because of the actions of
Wolverine Captain America simply just
died he just killed over now what it was
because his brain was scrambled or
something like that
isn't really explained it's really just
kind of a plot device to kill his hair
drop and initiate the story what we're
told is that after the death of Captain
America because he was such an important
symbol for the world and for the United
States the Avengers initially tried to
cover it up now again we're not really
told whose idea this was but I would go
as far as to say that because he's kind
of a dick he was probably Tony Stark but
but the overall theme here is that with
Captain America effectively gone
inevitably the information leaked out
someone somewhere told the press that
Steve Rogers was dead and because of
this America as a whole slipped into a
state of decay now the important thing
about this and what Marvel's really
telling us here is that Captain
America's is an icon you know he's more
than just a guy that runs around dressed
in the American flag beating people up
that he means something in the hearts
and minds of Americans and that because
he died it basically destroyed people's
will to have a country that would
continue down the path that they were
used to people effectively just gave up
now from here we switch to Tony Stark
talking to the Punisher and what we're
told here is that somewhere along the
line after the death of Captain America
the United States most likely fell into
war now I would say this was probably a
civil war but the fact remains that we
fell into a war in our entirety and the
country went to pieces because of it and
so what Tony Stark does is as he's
talking to Frank Castle he basically
says that Frank castles a broken man and
he has been since his family died but
even more so with this particular war
having to watch innocent people struggle
in a way that he hadn't seen since his
time in Vietnam it broke him even more
than he was before
the significance of this is a Tony Stark
it's basically just playing on the
Punisher East buying on his emotions
playing on his thoughts and even goes as
far as to offer him the position to be
Captain America now this is a huge deal
and the reason why is because it
actually falls perfectly in line with
the nature of Frank Castle and what I
mean here is that Frank Castle during
the Civil War event had effectively
admitted that the whole reason why he
joined the Vietnam War why he enlisted
in the military to fight in that
conflict was because he idolized Captain
America Captain America was a hero
during World War two he fought against
the Axis powers against the Nazis and
Punisher in his own mind wanted to do
the exact same thing and so when he's
offered the position to be the new
Captain America by Tony Stark in the end
he can't really turn it down and so the
result is that were not really given
what goes on behind the scenes but
somewhere along the line the illuminati
of name with a submariner black bolt of
the Inhumans Tony Stark Reed Richards
Doctor Strange and Professor Xavier had
essentially come together and they had
altered the I guess the serum of Steve
Rogers and implanted it into the
Punisher now exactly how this was
modified again we're not really told
Marvel's just kind of throwing stuff at
us and they're not really giving us any
in-depth information here that you're
saying well things happened but what
Reed Richards does tell us is that
because they weren't able to duplicate
the serum of Abraham Erskine the person
that originally made Steve Rogers
Captain America instead Reed Richards
actually put his mind to tasks and
improved Etta this is really interesting
because we've never seen an instance in
Marvel Comics where Reed Richards has
worked on the Super Soldier Serum they
came Captain America has powers or gay I
guess given his abilities we've never
seen this before
as this is actually a really cool
concept the downside to this is that the
stories basically really poorly written
and so not much is done with it in terms
of explanation or what it was that that
that Reed Richards had done but the fact
remains that once once the Punisher
becomes Captain America or takes on the
mantle the country immediately starts to
recover now of course while he's
fighting these various doom bots again
the reason why this ties in is because
for the Punisher aside from killing him
in Captain America are the exact same
person the Punisher is going after bad
guys
he's defeating criminals he's not
killing them but he never really needed
- in the first place and the great thing
about this is that as a story continues
it basically just kind of grants you
know Frank Castle this solace that he's
been looking for it grants him a place
now again without Marvel giving us
really you know any real information
here I would say them in the mind of
Frank Castle this is really a necessity
this is something that he needed with
Steve Rogers being Captain America Frank
Castle couldn't be Captain America he
could only be the next best thing why it
made sense to him to simply go through
and start killing criminals is really
just within the context of whoever's
writing the Frank Castle stories at the
time and no one's really ever taken the
time to expand on why it is these
killing people aside from the fact that
his family was killed but in his
particular story he has something
greater to aspire to and this is really
what Tony Stark was hitting home about
when he initially offered him the
position and so what we're told is that
as time passes because Frank Castle is
more ruthless than Steve Rogers was
because he's willing to go that extra
limit to ensure that these criminals had
a better understanding of where they
relate to him as a person in the sense
that he beats the absolute hell out of
them the world begins to shift and it
begins to change no longer are things in
a situation whereby villains have
effectively taken over instead they're
beginning to retreat they're beginning
to cower and America's responding to
this very idea by pulling itself up by
its bootstraps and so from here we
basically pick up with what seems to be
the rest of the Avengers as well as
Frank Castle who has basically aspired
and rallied everyone together and so
because of this Tony Stark himself has a
has been able to rally back of course
build his empire even greater and larger
but more so than that the Frank Castle
Captain America has become a symbol for
the world he is now something that
everybody aspires to in the sense that
there are so many different heroes out
there who are becoming Captain America
we're at the very least acting in
accordance through dressing up as him
they're following the same tactics he's
effectively built a kind of a culture a
counterculture around himself now while
there are individuals here and there who
don't necessarily agree with his actions
one individual who does is a girl named
Ava now the reason why this matters is
because as the years begin to pass
Captain America stops being a symbol of
freedom within this particular story and
instead basically becomes a marketable
in the sense that people are selling
toys based on him they're selling all
different kinds of merchandise and so on
it's oh he's become a means to make
money now I don't necessarily think it
was the intention for this to happen it
just kind of unfolded that way because
of his popularity and so while even and
one of her friends are playing around
because Frank Castle has long since
retired from being Captain America the
notion here is that he's considered an
old fogey basically he's just kind of an
old guy that not very many people take
seriously but he also operates away from
the mantle of being Captain America he
operates away from this concept having
left it due to the fact that he became
disillusioned with the very concept of
Captain America as it had become a
marketable device and so the result here
is that while Ava begins to taunt him a
bit while she begins to uh to sort of
make not really make fun of him but in
the sense that she basically tries to
elicit a reaction from him what she
essentially says here is that she heard
the legends about Frank Castle Captain
America she heard the legends about how
great he was about how he fought off a
scroll invasion essentially the secret
invasion event how he was able to take
on Thanos you know by himself and
effectively defeat Thanos using both his
ruthlessness his intelligence and his
enhanced strength which was beyond what
Steve Rogers originally had but the
person that she's currently looking at
the man that she sees is a shadow of his
former self and the result here is that
Frank Castle effectively reacts he says
of the problem with this the problem
with the entire concept of Captain
America is that it's not about the
greatness of the country anymore it's
about how much money can be made on his
name and so having walked away from that
having left he didn't want to have
anything to do with the concept but for
Ava
Captain America despite being a
marketable concept despite being a means
to achieve great amounts of wealth from
those individuals who were making money
on that name he still stands for freedom
he still stands for what it means to be
America and to be a human being in the
eyes of the world and so while Frank
castle of course is hardened ways and
you know not really having a soft heart
so to speak effectively gives in what he
does is he begins training Ava
personally on how to become Captain
America and so as the story begins to
wrap up we eventually find that Ava had
enlisted as part of the US government
and effectively taken up a role as part
of the cap
Amerika core which is to say a huge part
of the world an army of people who were
all operating under the mantle of
Captain America with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end in truth the story's not bad but
it's not the best it's certainly not the
best what-if story but I thought it was
something relatively interesting so if
you guys enjoyed this video
just drop likes post comments let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace